SPEAKER: We have never added
a new programming language
to Android.
And today, we're making
Kotlin an officially supported
language in Android.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
WOJTEK KALICINSKI:
At Google IO, we
announced that we're adding
Kotlin as an officially
supported language for Android.
Kotlin is a mature
and fun language
that many developers are already
embracing for their production
apps.
For those of you who want to
try Kotlin for the first time,
we're now bundling
the Kotlin plug-in
with Android Studio 3.0.
When creating a new
project, you can now
choose to enable Kotlin
support, and any template
will be generated in
that language for you.
Because Kotlin plays
well with Java,
you can also start adding Kotlin
to your existing projects.
Try converting a single
Java file to Kotlin
using this Android
Studio command.
Or add a new code
template and select
Kotlin as the source language.
When taking first steps
with programming in Kotlin,
you might also find it useful to
migrate code snippets from Java
by simply copying and
pasting them to Kotlin files.
And Android Studio will convert
to code for you on the fly.
Refer to our blog post
on Android Developers
for a quick tour of
the Kotlin language.
You'll also find links to the
full reference pages there.
We're just starting with
Kotlin as a support language
for Android, so expect to see
more documentation, samples,
and Android specific
guidance in the future.
And in the meantime, I hope
you have fun exploring Kotlin.
[MUSIC PLAYING]